parce que nos villes se transforment
perpétuellement nous avons le devoir de
recycler tous ces matériaux
ipréma votre partenaire pour un
développement durable
bonjour et bienvenue dans équilibre le
magazine de l'environnement et du
développement durable au sommaire de ce
numéro pour réduire les factures
d'énergie la casquille et le département
ont décidé il y a quelques années de
modifier les éclairages publics une
carte interactive est en cours de
création sur le plateau de Saclay pour
tout découvrir de notre environnement 5
élèves d'un collège Guyon pour toi
participant à un atelier hebdomadaire
autour de l'écologie nous avons
participé à l'un d'entre eux
depuis quelques années la communauté
d'agglomération de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines est le
département ont décidé de modifier les
éclairages publics c'est un moyen de
réduire les dépenses énergétiques mais
aussi la pollution lumineuse engendrée
par nos villes William l et Elodie moine
pour les images
RD35 zone d'activité trapè-lancourt pas
de lumière alors que la nuit est tombée
mais pas d'erreur depuis un an le
Conseil Général n'allume plus les
lampadaires de cette route
départementale son objectif réduire la
consommation d'énergie et la pollution
lumineuse depuis 2011 en cumulant toutes
les économies d'énergie faites depuis
lors on arrive aujourd'hui si on compare
la situation avant 2011 à la situation
d'aujourd'hui à une économie d'énergie
par exemple de l'ordre de près de 2
millions de kilowattheure par an
économiser 30% des routes du département
sont actuellement concernées des lieux
où il n'y a pas de circulation piétonne
pour des raisons de sécurité ou de
problèmes de lisibilité de la route à
partir de là on a décidé une extinction
qui est une extinction pendant toute la
nuit voilà on éteint on débranche les
installations et on observe les
comportements les vitesses pratiquée par
les usagers notamment en veille et bien
évidemment à ce qu'il n'y ait pas
d'accident au premier accident lié à
l'absence d'éclairage bien sûr en
rallumerait les sections à partir de cet
été le Conseil Général enlèvera les
camps des labres sur les routes qui
depuis 2011 sont concernées par la
mesure à l'échelle locale cette volonté
d'économies et partagée par la
Communauté d'Agglomération depuis 2006
la casse qui teste sur plusieurs
communes l'abaissement depuis sens du
point lumineux sur les lampes donc des
ballasts électroniques équipées de
variations avec des scénarios préétablis
dont un que nous avons choisi est mis en
place sur une majorité de nos ouvrages
qui permet de diminuer de 30% le niveau
d'éclairement entre 22h30 et 6h du matin
c'est le moment où il y a moins de
circulation sur les voiries la
communauté d'agglomération gère 25000
points lumineux situés sur tout 51 en
Yvelines outre la variation de la
puissance a été mis en place la
réduction du temps d'allumage des
horloges astronomiques ont été installés
permettant un éclairage en relation avec
le lever et le coucher du soleil
certains ouvrages eux ont été modernisés
on peut prendre l'exemple de la rue qui
se trouve derrière nous la rue ocre nous
avons remplacé 16 scandales équipés de
lampes de 125 watts par 16 scandellares
équipées de lampes palais de 40 watts
donc d'un côté nous avions en
consommation 2000 watts et nous sommes
passés à 600 watts donc nous avons fait
une économie sur cette rue d'environ 70%
. chaque année les candélabre de
l'agglomération sont allumées 3900
heures autre mesure mise en place
l'extinction totale des éclairages pour
les parcs et jardins fermés au public de
quoi profiter aussi de notre ciel étoilé
si vous demandez où trouver des AMAP des
agriculteurs ou des sites liés à la
biodiversité une carte est actuellement
construction sur le plateau de Saclay
elle référence aussi l'agglomération de
Saint-Quentin et pour en parler nous
sommes avec Dorian Spaak bonjour Dorian
bonjour vous êtes chargés de mission à
l'association Terre et cité est-ce que
vous pouvez me parler de cette carte oui
alors la carte ouverte en fait c'est un
projet qui est né du constat qui avait
une richesse patrimoniale agricole etc
sur l'ensemble de ces territoires la
petite région agricole du plateau de
Saclay
mais qui en même temps n'était pas du
tout connu du grand public c'est pas du
tout connu d'une part et pas du tout
accessible d'autre part et du coup
c'était l'idée de créer un outil qui à
la fois référence l'ensemble de ces
points d'intérêt et à la fois les rangs
accessibles à travers un petit
calculateur d'itinéraires piétons et
vélo et comment elle s'est construite
alors elle s'est construite en lien avec
un projet de recherche qui était financé
par le ministère du Développement
durable et des transports qui visait à
étudier les mobilités actives donc la
marche de vélo sur un territoire
périurbain donc le plateau de Saclay est
un territoire préféré aux mains par
excellence et du coup on a travaillé
avec un cabinet d'études sur les
mobilité avec une école d'architecture
de Paris malakais avoir comment on
pouvait justement faciliter l'accès au
cœur agricole et naturel du territoire à
partir des RER des Francs urbaines etc
aujourd'hui nous sommes à la ferme de
Villepin c'est elle qui nous accueille
c'est un des lieux référencés et je vous
propose maintenant d'écouter anime
Colombo qui est chargée de la carte
ouverte pour nous dire tout ce qu'on est
trop donc on y trouve différentes
rubriques et donc c'est on a une
rubrique donc vraiment le qui correspond
au cœur de tes récité qui est la
rubrique agriculture culture étant au
pluriel pour englober donc d'une part
toutes les exploitations agricoles du
plateau on a également tout ce qui est
jardinage citoyen donc les initiatives
de jardin partagé les vergers communaux
etc on trouve la pédagogie de
l'environnement avec par exemple la
Maison de l'Environnement de la
communauté d'agglomération Paris-Saclay
voilà on vient surtout parler de ce
qu'on trouve au niveau de l'agriculture
est-ce qu'il a d'autres choses à
découvrir sur cette carte cette carte
elle a aussi une volonté fonctionnelle
pour les acteurs qui participent à la
vie du territoire donc on va trouver par
exemple les salles qui sont disponibles
pour les associations pour organiser des
réunions des pays manifestations on a
une partie on a une partie actualité qui
est plus dynamique on a on vient
d'intégrer l'agenda de la commune de
Magny-les-Hameaux donc tous les
événements qui sont organisés en
partenariat avec la commune se
retrouvent maintenant sur la carte
l'ambition au-delà de la dimension
agricole naturelle etc dont tu as parlé
à Nîmes d'apporter voilà tout ce qui
fait la vie du territoire et surtout de
partager cette vie du territoire au-delà
des limites communales et des limites
intercommunales puisque le plateau de
Saclay rassemble trois communautés
d'agglomération différentes elle en est
où cette carte elle est déjà fini ou pas
alors la carte est lancée elle est
fonctionnelle elle est accessible en
ligne dès aujourd'hui et même depuis
plusieurs mois après c'est une carte qui
est encore de construction dans le sens
où on a un nombre de rubriques assez
important et donc du coup il y a
certaines rubriques qui sont encore pas
très fournies donc on y travaille
aujourd'hui notamment en associant
maintenant à la démarche un certain
nombre d'autres organismes qui n'ont pas
construit la carte mais qui viennent y
participer maintenant en apportant de la
formation donc on pense que d'ici l'été
elle sera vraiment assez complète en
termes d'information proposée et il y a
une autre démarche en parallèle qui est
maintenant de construire la gouvernance
justement de cet outil avec l'ensemble
des acteurs locaux pour pouvoir gérer et
c'est l'enjeu maintenant sur le long
terme la qualité de l'information
fournie avec tout ce que vous avez
référencé est-ce que vous avez déjà des
petits secrets à partager des endroits
des personnes à rencontrer ou à avoir
mais quelque chose d'assez intéressant
dont nous on n'avait pas conscience en
agissant principalement sur les
questions d'agriculture etc c'est la
richesse du tissu de l'économie sociale
et solidaire sur le territoire on a un
partenaire qui travaille spécifiquement
sur ces questions là et on s'est rendu
compte qu'il y avait beaucoup
d'entreprises d'initiatives etc qui
avait ces démarches là et ça contribue
vraiment à notre avis à la richesse
justement de ce territoire merci Dorian
spa pour cet éclairage
dans équilibre on parle souvent de ce
que nous pouvons faire pour notre
planète mais l'écologie peut aussi faire
pour nous et plus précisément pour
plusieurs élèves du collège les soldes
lui en cours qui depuis le mois de
septembre participent à un atelier
autour de cette problématique un
reportage réalisé avec Patrick Jacques
de Dixmude
ces affiches ce ne sont pas des
professionnels qui en sont à l'origine
mais eux Kaï c'est Lucas sont deux des
cinq élèves des co-collège on débute on
sait qu'il y avait pas beaucoup de
choses j'ai beaucoup cherché mais
ensuite j'ai vu qu'il y avait beaucoup
de choses que je savais pas ça me
donnait envie d'apprendre donc du coup
je regarde un peu plus de documentaire
avant que je regarde pas énormément
lucas doit réaliser des photos pour une
nouvelle campagne d'information et qu'au
collège a choisi d'expliquer aux autres
élèves la différence entre le bac à pile
du bureau des surveillants et les
poubelles de l'établissement moi ça me
plaît de de faire ça parce que c'est
bien pour l'environnement et
et voilà je trouve c'est sympa c'est pas
bien de mettre les déchets par terre
enfin si on a des déchets on le met dans
la poubelle et qu'au collège c'est un
collectif mis en place à la rentrée de
septembre par l'équipe pédagogique pour
lutter contre le décrochage et la
violence scolaire puisqu'on fait part
double les élèves les élèves qui ont des
difficultés sur le plan scolaire en
terme de résultats et en termes de
comportement il y en a quelques-uns bien
entendu plutôt que de laisser comme ça
et de ne rien leur proposer de monter ce
dispositif pour eux et en quelques mois
leur comportement évolué les cinq
collégiens se retrouvent chaque vendredi
après-midi un moment d'échange avec leur
enseignants où ils apprennent notamment
l'autonomie on n'a pas non plus une
exigence classique c'est à dire que
c'est pas des devoirs à faire mais bon
suivant ce que chacun apporte on fait si
les élèves alors qu'ils avaient prévu de
faire quelque chose sont pas là ou n'ont
pas fait ce qu'ils avaient à faire ben
on va plus lentement mais c'est un
apprentissage collectif du coup
la deuxième heure va bientôt commencer
Lilian et ml d'une les rejoignent pour
travailler sur leur court-métrages le
scénario un professeur transformé en
zombie à cause de produits toxiques
direction une salle de classe pour une
dernière répétition avant le tournage
mais laissons les travailler
l'hiver prend fin nous avait encore le
temps de tailler vos arbres fruitiers si
vous ne savez pas comment faire voici
les conseils de l'ancien responsable du
Potager du Roi de Versailles
et les outils prêts elle l'avait au
désinfectant la taille peut commencer
ces adhérents de l'association jardin
passions par Tage sont venus chercher
conseil pour prendre soin de leurs
arbres fruitiers en plein repos
végétatif la taille ça s'apprend et
surtout ça se pratique vous savez c'est
pas une salutation qu'on arrive à
tailler parce que c'est toujours assez
complexe c'est jamais pareil
à un autre regardez les branches qui
sont vers l'horizontale ou vers le
brique ou vers le bas et son elles sont
chargées de bouton à fruits donc ça ça
va aussi un petit peu équilibrer l'arbre
mais toujours au ras d'une production
aura d'un organe végétatif jamais
jamais au petit bonheur la chance en
disant voilà je coupe là c'est trop long
je m'arrête là non j'ai toujours
réfléchi trois types de taille sont
possibles celles de fructification celle
de formation permettant de donner une
forme à un arbre mais aussi celle de
restauration pour les arbres plus âgés
si la taille se fait en général une fois
par an il est parfois nécessaire d'en
faire une seconde quand il y a trop de
fouilles sur un arbre au mois de juin
vous éclaircissez
ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire
laisser deux fruits par bouquet autre
geste à adopter l'application d'un
cicatrisant à base de résine et d'argile
pour soigner les plaies d'un arbre c'est
une sorte d'écorce artificielle mais
avant de cicatriser quand on a fait une
coupe à la scie
on passe on passe la serpette au tour de
la coupe
on dit on part il faut parer la plaie
si l'hiver est la bonne période pour
tailler les arbres à Pépin cela noyau
doivent être l'été ou après la récolte
ces arbres là sont taillés il ne reste
plus qu'à laisser le temps faire son
travail
avons-nous quitter noter ces quelques
rendez-vous la Maison de l'Environnement
projette le documentaire Nagat Leon la
présentatrice on n'est pas que des
cobayes autour du futur dans lequel
vivront les enfants c'est avoir le
vendredi 27 mars pensez à réserver le
printemps arrive et à cette occasion
Versailles propose diverses activités et
notamment la création d'un jardin
éphémère autour de la biodiversité et si
vous voulez découvrir les produits
d'entretien et de beauté écologique
n'hésitez pas à vous inscrire à
l'atelier du 11 avril au musée de la
ville voilà équilibre c'est terminé je
vous donne rendez-vous le mois prochain
et d'ici là pensez à faire un geste pour
l'environnement